yeah i should have done a video on
monday so that would be yesterday or day
before yesterday depending on when i get
this video up look don't blame me blame
ghost of tsushima how how addicting is
that game oh i suppose that is my own
slothfulness so you can go ahead and
blame me point is
you're looking to escape the bus fire of
2020 found the perfect movie let's talk
about it
[Music]
castaway so castaway was directed by
robert zemeckis it stars tom hanks also
came out in the year 2000
tom hanks plays this fedex the
supervisor of some sort i don't know his
exact position because i don't know the
fedex structure ponies is a very fast
talking go get him kind of guy you know
tick tock tick tock tick tock live and
dive by the clock
he's hitching a ride on this airplane
that deviates off course
to avoid a storm and then the plane goes
down and
so now he's stranded on an island and
nobody knows where he is so now he is a
castaway and i'm gonna give a spoiler
warning yes the movie's coming up on 20
years old at this point but still i
i mean i'm not going to step by step
take you through but i do
talk about the ending and so spoiler
boarding no it seems only fair i'll give
you the spoiler warning the trailer
never gave us
if there are any lists out there of
movie trailers that ruined the movie
i imagine castaway is on every single
one of them i remember this trailer
clearly i worked at the movie theater at
the time i was a projectionist and this
movie trailer
showed the entire movie from beginning
to end
right down to the last shot of the
trailer being the last shot of the movie
wait strike that reverse it oh i guess
it works that way
point is it's weird man
it's a bad trailer but a really good
movie so that's what i like about the
fact that i revisited castaway because i
hadn't seen it since it came out
on vhs so now that it's a couple decades
later so now i can stop being pissy
about the fact that the trailer showed
the entire movie
and i can just enjoy castaway for what
it is and what it is is definitely
the tom hanks show this is tom hanks
from beginning to end because
most of the movie is tom hanks on this
island
alone it never cuts back to the mainland
of people
may or may not be looking for him it
doesn't show how helen hunt who plays
his girlfriend of the movie doesn't show
how she's processing it
you're just here with tom hanks on this
island well tom hanks and the
volleyball wilson which is a great
supporting character and that's one of
the things i like about castaway
cassaway has some great philosophical
points just about
human beings in general and wilson in
this movie is one of them it shows that
in isolation people will
try to find some form of normal
interaction
not every movie that deals with
isolation deals with
people's apparent need for what they
consider
normal human interaction and the lengths
they'll go to try to achieve that when
there are no human beings around i mean
i'm no doctor or psychologist but when i
see
tom hanks interacting with wilson the
volleyball and his
connection with wilson i don't see a
crazy person i see a sane person i see
someone's brain trying their hardest to
keep them sane it's just one of the many
fantastic elements in this movie now for
the first
we'll call it half of the time we see
tom hanks his character on this island
he's
he just lands there he's definitely
nurtured by the outside world and
i mean you look at this guy he looks
like any of us who would just be
stranded on this island
he's trying to figure out how to survive
in this place the second half
is a four year jump and now we see he's
he's a veteran of the craft he's much
skinnier now he's made really efficient
tools out of all the garbage he found
washed up on the shore from the little
fedex boxes his hair is long his beard
is long no i'm not trying to go there
i am i'll be honest with you i'll stop
at the jason momoa
you think i'm messing with you no it's
just so i could be like permission to
come aboard
it's gonna be epic but there was
something i noticed this time
that my more youthful brain picked up at
the subconscious level and i didn't
i didn't see it then now i'm like oh
smart move there was something about
this movie that always felt more
grounded more
real less theatrical i just i always
felt like i was
on this island with this character more
than any other movie about a person
being stranded on an island that i could
think about or think of
rather better phrase and that's because
there's no musical score in this movie
he's on this
island and there's just there's no music
except
it's the time you start singing the
doors that's your music other than that
there's no musical score until
much later and the fact that there was
no musical score until that point made
that moment ever more impactful music
in a movie is it's the great manipulator
of cinema you know it's
the filmmaker's way of massaging your
emotional state
into the state they require for you to
process the
scene in the way they want you to
process it action scenes are more
intense because of the music dramatic
scenes are more dramatic because of the
music but in terms of
castaway the emotional state you get is
from tom hanks
showing emotion when he shows emotion
he's thinking about his girlfriend you
really
feel it but there's no musical
manipulation there really you're just
you're on this island so it allows you
to process this scenario how you would
process it you feel like
you're on the island and i'm gonna be
real with you for as long as i can
remember that's just
a fascinating thought to me the fact
that there are a multitude of successful
shows and movies about people being
stranded on islands i don't feel i'm
alone in this
maybe it was because i cast away
probably earlier than that
maybe even gilligan's island gave me
this sensation i always felt that it was
a fascinating
thought to be stranded on an island like
you know what would i do and
i feel like the reason that myself and a
lot of people are
drawn to that thought is because it's
it's like adamus said in battlestar
galactica i forgot
exactly how he said this i'm going to
paraphrase he said something along the
lines of
never underestimate people's want for a
fresh start and that is
what being stranded on an island would
give you it's
it is in its way a fresh start and
that's really what tom hanks gets
in this movie as a fresh start tom hanks
is quoted as saying something along the
lines of
being stranded on that island was the
best thing that could have happened to
his character in the movie and i don't
disagree i mean you look at the guy
he's high strung he's a workaholic
whether or not he wants to be a
workaholic i don't know or
maybe he's just trapped in that work
environment he just has to be a
workaholic because that's what the job
requires but he's living and dying by
his calendar
and then boom he's on this island and
now things are different which is funny
because his live and die by the clock
philosophy does help him
when he's trying to get off the island
but when he first gets on that island
at no point is he like oh did i pay the
electric bill
no it's more real than that you know
it's things get
very simple very fast in that kind of
scenario this isn't just a movie about a
guy on an island it's a movie about
commencement it's a movie about someone
literally entering the state of change
and becoming another person in another
life and he does
emerge from this scenario with a
different outlook on life and it can
strongly be
argued that it is a better one all the
noise and stress of life that he
considered
necessary elements of life that weren't
are gone now they're washed away they're
not just left on the island they're left
on the shoulders of a guy who legally
died when he was on the island he now
gets to proceed in life with this
newfound perspective for life and for a
lot of us myself included it would
probably take
a plane crash on an island to get us
there and in that
in my way i envy him which brings me to
the end of castaway and i think the end
of this movie is perfectly ambiguous for
the theme they're going for here it
leaves you on this note of
oh what happens next when i was younger
when this movie was in theaters and i
saw it i hated the ending but now 20
years later i see it as a perfect ending
the theme of a crossroad an uncertain
possibility is which path
should you choose that is completely not
what would have worked for this
character in the beginning of this movie
he can roll with that uncertainty where
he
couldn't before that's what castaway is
castaway to me is just the theme of life
anyhow of all the movies
of people being stranded on islands
castaway is the one that really hits me
to the core
of how i kind of see the scenario among
tom hanks's performance the the
fascination
of this guy figuring out how to survive
on this island then figuring out how to
get off of this island the transition
from
one state of mind and one life to the
other and the brilliant cult and not
have a musical score while he's on the
island
there's a lot in castaway that works for
me if youtube was around
back when this movie came out and if i
did reviews back when this movie came
out it probably would have been one of
my favorite movies of that year
it's not just about a guy on an island
it's an individual personal story about
human beings it's about you it's about
me it's about
all of us and i feel like most anyone
who watches castaway
with if you're looking for that you'll
find that here and i'll say castaway is
awesome tacular
[Music]
all right so castaway have you seen it
what did you think about it or what's
another movie about someone being
stranded on an island that
you dig and what's your favorite if it's
not castaway if it is cast away well
tell me what you like about castaway
point is whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to come
aboard
[Music]
you